okay so can you connect Klein bottles
together and if so what do you get well
now I take a Mobius loop right I give up
half twist get a Mobius loop what if I
give it another half twist turns out
that's not a Mobius loop it's two-sided
give it yet another half twist it
becomes a Mobius loop probably the most
famous Mobius loop has three half twists
to it
it's the recycle sign and you can see
there's 1 2 3 half twist to it
that's a Mobius loop just like that's a
Mobius loop to be a Mobius loop you have
to be able to walk on all one side
without crossing an edge yep ok got that
one
oh my fingers are blue from having tried
to put blue dye into a Klein bottle
ignore that they'll wash off in the next
two or three weeks so I can make a three
twist Mobius loop can I do the same
thing with a Klein bottle what if I take
a Klein bottle and add another Klein
bottle to it oh I can go over the glass
shop get a scissors cut that there but
that there get another one and build
this is this a Klein bottle it's two
Klein bottles welded together
oh let's get up pen okay let's start
over here and write the letter A and the
letter B well let's start at a going
along here oh I can't keep going I'm on
the inside of this party still on the
inside still on the inside still on the
inside
well come out over here and I come back
to 8:00 so I can go from a all the way
back to a but I never get to the letter
B meaning that this side here the a side
is different from the B side B and a are
on different sides so cliff someone
watching might be thinking oh I can just
run my finger directly from A to B but
you're you're cheating if you go like
this and go bonk like that no we're
talking about we're talking about a
mathematical thing like this where where
where Mike glassblower had actually
caught a hole here so you can go zip
through it go around the inside nah this
is something this is a figment of our
figment of our three-dimensional
universe so that's so ignore that one
that's self-intersection does that
self-intersection doesn't come from the
outside here gee now you're on the
inside of this now you're on the outside
of this in your back there so this turns
out to have two sides and hold there
this is homeomorphic to a torus okay got
that what if I add another one to this
I'll go from here to here here's three
klein bottles arranged well let's try
the same experiment
I'll write a over here B and C okay
triple Klein bottle go from a over here
no I'm on the inside beep
still on the inside
I come out here and I'm on the outside
of C okay
outside of C go back here outside
outside outside outside Oh Luke I end up
on the inside of a ah around the inside
of eight I'm now right behind her so
without lifting the pen from the surface
of the class I've gone from the outside
from the outside over here over to the
inside this is one sided let's keep
going I'm still on the inside of this
one honey a millimeter away from here is
wearing target I see still on the inside
stony inside I come around here I've hit
the outside of hit beat Hot Diggity ah
cool now I come around and I'm on the
outside
through there now I'm on the inside of
this and I've reached the other side of
the sea surface i stand that other side
come out here I am back to where I
started I've covered the entire surface
an ant could walk on the entire surface
of this just ignoring the places were
you can't get through so this is a clan
battle it's one-sided there's no edge
and no point is there sharp edge that
the caterpillar crawling the surface
ever got cut on you could paint the
whole thing by pouring paint over one
side and the vets rating if I if I hired
a painter they could paint the whole
thing with one side and one color piece
of cake works like gangbusters showed
this to a friend of mine
Lucas Clarke glassblower he thought
about it for a while he said why you're
trying to tell me that any even number
of klein bottles linked together as a
torus any odd number one three five is a
Klein bottle I said yeah that makes
sense
he makes a Klein bottle of 17 individual
Klein bottle units Brady check this out
check this out each of these each little
unit is a Klein bottle and if you count
them you'll count 17 Klein bottles but
wait wait to show how nutty lucas's each
plane model in this linked set of 17
Klein models twists just enough so that
it's a Mobius loop of Klein bottles he
actually made a mistake but I'll ignore
it don't tell anyone that he sort of
flipped one around this is a mobius
ring' of Klein models just as you could
say that a Klein bottle is the connected
sum of two Mobius loops here's the
connected sum of 17 plain bottles as a
mobius ring'
you're amazing what's a hard to make was
it hard to make oh why why why knock on
the door at that glass shop I won't say
that everybody runs and hides but
multiple Klein bottle manufacturing such
as this or 3x turtle Klein bottles or
suppose instead of making three Klein
bottles by cutting these together and
hang them together like this suppose I
removed this section and put a smaller
Klein bottle right there sorry cut this
and build it in there and that over here
I go take this part out you cut that out
and put an even smaller Klein bottle in
so I have three Klein bottles which are
internally linked rather than externally
linked well in that case I'll end up
with something that looks like this
okay this is homeomorphic to this Klein
bottle both of which are homeomorphic to
an ordinary regular Klein bottle like
this guy here this is three internally
linked Klein bottles so this hole here
is map well is really the same as this
hole here and that leads outward through
this tube coming back to the next one in
goes to here comes up and around out
here that tube goes to another fine
bottle which is completely linked up
here and comes out this way to the
outside
which comes back to here in other words
here's a triple Klein bottle which has
the same properties as this triple Klein
bottle which internal which in turn have
the same properties as this guy which
also have the same properties as this
Klein bottle all of which is to say if
you're looking for zero volume one sided
are three immersed not embedded Klein
bottles uh there's plenty eight to
explore with glass Brady if you're going
to show Felix Klein behind a Klein
bottle
there's mobius framed by a Mobius loop
you've already broken at 170 I've broken
at once and Adams and George George
Chittenden over to Adam from Chittenden
glass laughed at me and said I'll fix it
for you just this once he patch it up
just so I'm not gonna I treat it with
delicacy enjoy it's a the idea of making
a seventeen unit Klein bottle into a
Mobius loop Oh Lucas Clark over here
Lucas is a complete nut I'm gonna have
to take pictures of this tonight friend
now so she knows what the big okay